how's it goin everybody welcome to this
week's ask a career coach my name is
Martin McGovern and today we're gonna be
talking initially about resumes what
makes a good one how long should it be
what are the debates about your resume
that we can dig into so if you have any
resume questions right off the bat
please put them in the chat we've got
care in there and she's gonna be passing
along any questions you have to me so
that we can turn this career discussion
into a QA excited to hear where you're
all joining us from I'm currently in
Chicago where it went from being a
beautiful sunny day almost sixty degrees
almost to a terribly crazy thunderstorm
with a huge lot of fog coming in over
the lake so now I'm a weatherman but
it's just kind of crazy it's all coming
in right outside the window is huge fog
just lifting in so where are you joining
us from in the world and what is it
what's the weather like out by you I
know it's a generic chatting question
the generic small talk but we are in the
beginning of a you know hour-long chat
here about your career so let's just
wait for everyone to show up pass the
time a little bit for the next four
minutes or so to give people time to
join and then we'll be diving into your
questions of course if you have
questions that you've brought to the
chat today or that you didn't get
answered in previous calls please put
them in the discussion in the chat there
Karen will grab them send them over to
me and we will dig into all of your
questions during our call today super
excited to hear what's on your mind and
what direction you'd like this
conversation to go again we're just
going to wait a few minutes and I'll
start giving a shout to folks from all
over the world who are joining us today
all right we got Algeria we got a resume
question coming in Minneapolis weather
is gorgeous
40 degrees glorious sorry 40 degrees
Nepal India Spain Canada welcome back
everyone
by the way if you've been joining us for
these sessions each week I want to say
thank you and welcome back if you're
brand new here the way this works is I
stand here you ask questions and we dig
into it the more detail you can give the
better so if you're asking questions
about like you know what should I I
think we had a question like is this job
right for me well you know it's hard to
say I'll give my best general answer but
the more detail you can get the better
of course and and also you know my
background is in marketing education
career development things of that sort
so I can definitely help with anything
interview related resume related cover
letter related and so on how to promote
yourself how to sell yourself but when
it comes to very specific technical
questions some of a Mike over my head
because I am NOT a developer and in
those cases we'll just put it back to
the community point you in the direction
of the right people to talk to and so on
but will will be keeping it a little bit
non-technical this week and every week
that I chat on these and so bring us
your questions I'm really excited to
hear what's on your mind San Jose and
10:30 p.m. in India thanks for staying
up late Sierra Leone India India Greece
San Francisco Pakistan India this is
your fifth session welcome back son geez
excited to have you here
right Trinidad India another India
hungry welcome Egypt another India
first-timer welcome we got India Morocco
conquer Bay California weather is
glorious will jealous little jealous
looks like we had a little bit of an
issue with daylight savings time and the
reminders going out so I appreciate you
all joining us from the YouTube
reminders and just you know from Twitter
Instagram wherever you're hearing this
stuff from Syria Arabia Morocco we're
looking for some resume refreshers
Palestine India Egypt Costa Rica Costa
Rica you don't on there got another new
timer welcome AVI Brazil India India
India love it great we've got some great
questions coming and thank you all for
submitting your questions we're about
five minutes into the call so I'm gonna
get the the answers rolling pretty soon
and we've got a real good turnout in the
chat here so thank you all for joining
us we've got New York we got Egypt we
got Germany
right here we go we're about five
minutes in so we're gonna get started
how can you make your resume stand out
this is going to be our kickoff question
today while we are putting together
while we're collecting any additional
questions from you and so what I want to
talk about when it comes to the resume
are a few different things the first
thing is that your resume is a
promotional material is promotional
material for your job search so when
you're thinking about it you really need
to think about it in the right way most
people think of their resume as a place
to just dump information for other
people to interpret but the issue with
that is that if you're just writing the
resume to get it to get information on
paper you're not actually keeping your
reader in mind and this is a marketing
concept that we don't typically think
about but if you ever go anywhere right
and someone's trying to sell you
something what is easier to read a
three-page pamphlet that goes into
extreme detail about everything you've
ever done or a one-page ad on a wall for
a concert or something that really
quickly communicates the main point that
you need to know which one is going to
be easier for someone to consume easier
for them to take action on we have a lot
of different promotional materials that
we use during the job search we have our
personal website we have our LinkedIn
profile we have our resume we have our
cover letter we have all sorts of
different things that communicate our
expertise could be your github could be
any number of different profiles so when
you're thinking about your resume you
have to know how it fits into your
promotional roadmap how does it fit into
your suite of promotional items and the
key thing to remember as well is that
the people reading your resume are
likely working in HR or our hiring
managers they're likely not the most
technical people now your resume will
also get to the technical person at the
end of the day the type of the hiring
manager the person is leading the team
but it's going to go through some
non-technical people before it gets to
the technical person so you want to
write your resume in a way that people
can understand it no matter who they are
in the company if you fill your resume
with an entirely with jargon it's going
to be very difficult for someone to
understand what you're what you've
actually done so a few things to keep in
mind one length of a resume I being a
marketer think that the shorter and more
concise something is the better I very
much encourage everyone to get their
resume down to a single page I actually
knew someone in college who had only had
a couple of odd jobs and they showed up
at a career fair with a three-page
resume and I flipped through and I'm
like there's no reason this thing should
be three pages long
you could condense here you could cut it
here no first of all you're gonna have
to get a stapler when you hand it to
people like it's just too much work how
can you make your resume easy to read
easy to give to someone easy for them to
digest and understand what it is you do
why you do it and how you could be a
value to them you have to keep your
reader in mind and so what we want to do
if possible is to cut your resume down
to a page and only include the most
relevant information so how do you do
this well we have a lot of things that
we've done over our career right but not
every single thing is relevant to the
role at hand so what I like to do is
make a master resume this is your resume
that has every job you've ever done has
every bullet of every project that
you've ever accomplished in all these
jobs it could be three pages four pages
however long you want to make it you
have that always and you're always
adding to it over the years then when
you see a job posting what you do is you
go through the job posting and you say
alright this requirement for the job
relates to this experience I have and
you highlight it this one in this one
this one in this one this one in this
one then you cull down your resume you
simplify your resume so that it only
talks to the things that are read
to that role now if it's less than a
page you want to add in a few other
things to really build it out to make it
fill that page but you don't want to
just leave it you don't want to include
everything in the kitchen sink so keep
that in mind when building your resume
I've seen people with extremely
comprehensive work histories who are
able to get the resume down to a page of
relevant information for the hiring
manager to read number two don't make it
so technical that someone like me can't
understand it I should be able to read
your resume and understand not only what
you've done but also the impact that
it's had on the company so let's say you
built a program that utilize certain
api's that allowed let's say you've
built a little like movie sorting app or
something right I use I built the
program using these api's that allowed
users to sort movies in a Netflix tile
so we set it up by saying here's what
I've done and here was the outcome so
when you're thinking about your bullet
points a lot of times I see people just
say built app using these languages
all right built app using these
languages doesn't tell me what the
outcome was was it you know an app that
lets people do XY and Z tell me that
give me a little bit of context so I'm
not just reading a bunch of jargon all
the way through your resume the other
thing to keep in mind is that when
you're putting together these resumes
you want to frame it all up as though
you are someone who provides value to
these companies so again this this is
something I try to emphasize in all of
our different application materials is
are you thinking about how you bring
value to the company so again take a
look at that job description see what
the things are that they have listed
maybe even network and talk to people at
the company what is the company trying
to accomplish what does their website
need how can you showcase bullets that
show you have a capability that can
solve that need these are the kinds of
things and again we're limited in a
resume format because of the bullets and
the way it's set up but you just need to
make it simple
clear and readable and really at the end
of the day this is what you need to know
the amount of time someone will spend
looking at your resume is about six
seconds so you want to make sure that
the key information is up top you want
to make sure that they understand who
like what you're able to what value
you're able to bring to the team very
quickly and then they'll be moving on
and looking at your LinkedIn sorry it's
a little hot in here so I'm going to
take off the sweater all right so that's
just a couple of things to keep in mind
when thinking about the resume now I'm
sure that this brought up more questions
than answers so please put your
questions in the chat and we'll be
diving into them over the next 45
minutes all right
superfab you have the first question how
far back should a resume go this is a
really good question and one that I
think varies depending on your
experience so typically anything over 10
years old isn't very relevant to the job
that you're applying to
especially because technology changes so
quickly and things of that sort now if
you've been working at the same company
for 15 years then of course something
that's 10 years old is still relevant
right but you might want to break that
up into all the different roles that
you've had at that company and maybe
merge a few of the older ones so that it
doesn't take up so much room on your
resume typically what you want to do is
just include everything that you've done
maybe in the last five to ten years
that's relevant to this role that fits
on a page and so again it depends on how
much stuff you have
in your work history but I would include
just you know at least three different
roles different types of experience that
you've had to give a variety and then
put three bullets under each one of
those to show your work history and your
ability to you know not just do this job
but work within a team do different you
know carry on different responsibilities
and things of that sort so probably if
it's over ten years old it's not so much
relevant anymore
and make sure that whatever you're
including fits on a page if possible
again that fitting on a page if possible
it's a debatable thing a lot of people
think a two-page resume is fine but just
knowing my experience of reading resumes
so many resumes and talking to so many
recruiters they won't very likely flip
to the next page so if you can get it
all to one it's a way to go all right
our second question by Pat Eve peda B's
I'm sorry I'm I'm really bad at
pronouncing names if you have any
resources for how I can learn to
pronounce names I would love that trying
to get better at it how long should my
ideal reson how long should my ideal
resume be what should I add first my
extracurricular projects or my work
experience great questions so like I've
said before there is some debate and how
long a resume should be but I personally
believe from my marketing background and
talking with a lot of recruiters and
reviewing a lot of resumes that a resume
should not be more than a page you can
get a lot of information across in one
page if you do it correctly so if you if
you really really can't get it to a page
you know hit me up we can talk maybe you
need a second page to go to but then
again if you're gonna go to a second
page you better fill that second page if
you do a page in a half then it just
looks like you're not able to format a
resume correctly and again a lot of what
a resume is is just proving that you
have the competency to build a resume
and the great thing is is that if you go
to like Google Drive and you do some
searches for resume templates or just
Google resume templates you'll find a
lot of amazing templates that you can
use to put together a really
nice-looking resume that isn't going to
be you know totally encumbered by like
all the different I don't know back in
the day we used to try and make it in
Word with a lot of tables and different
things like that it's just that's so
complicated
a lot of this design work is already
done for you if you just go online and
find it which should I had first
my extracurricular projects are my work
experience this is a this is really
important to think about because it
depends on what's most relevant to the
role if your education and your projects
are the most important put that first or
most relevant put that first make sure
that what you are putting at the top of
the resume is the thing that you want
them to remember you know my education
at this point in my career is really not
that important what's more important are
the companies I'm working with the
projects I'm working on so I put that at
the front front and center and then my
education is very small almost as a
footnote in the bottom of my resume so
if you're trying to think of what to put
first the way I have it because I have a
fair amount of experience in my area I
have my experience my my work experience
then I have my personal projects
volunteer work and then I have education
down here and skills in a in a margin on
the on the left hand side now everyone's
resume is gonna look a little bit
different but it all depends on what's
most relevant so sit down look at your
resume prioritize the most relevant work
I'll help you put together the rest of
your format
all right gem ting for the summary
section this is a very very open-ended
question I can tell already because
we're talking about the summary section
in the beginning part of a resume what
is better a bullet point of skills so
for the summary section the beginning of
the resume which is better a bullet
point of skills or three to five
sentences of experience and skills I've
seen this summary done lots and lots of
different ways to varying success what I
would say is when you're thinking about
the summary section what you want to do
is communicate why this industry and
company are interesting and why you're
right for the role so I don't think a
bullet point of skills would be the
right way to go because we should have a
skills section on your resume that
bullet points out your skills I also
don't think three to five sentences of
experience and things like that is the
right way to go just listing it because
you're going to get into your experience
in the experience section and three to
five sentences is a lot of room that
you're taking up at the top of a resume
that could be used to showcase more
bullets underneath each one of your
skills sorry just a second we have
another question that I'll get to in
just a moment okay so I wouldn't
recommend putting three to five
sentences at the top of your resume just
because it is so much space that you're
taking up so what I would do is say like
the reason what what is the reason that
you are doing what you do right so for
me it's to help people find work that
they love right so that's very simple my
goal is to help people find work that
they love and I merge my background in
marketing career development and let's
say content creation in order to help
people get this outcome now of course
there's a better way that I would write
that out rather than doing off the top
of my
head butt that's like one to two
sentences it's very short explains why
I'm here and it also explains what I do
so if you want to make it really simple
let's just make it super simple for you
what is it about the industry that this
job that you're applying for what what
is interesting about it and we should be
pretty focused on what industry we're
looking at right so let's say I talked
to someone recently who's really
interested in working in media right so
their summary would be something along
the lines of I'm really interested in
improving the ways in which people
connect and communicate utilizing
technology I merge my background in they
had worked in media and advertising I
merged our background and media and
advertising and programming to help
improve technological communications for
for companies so that's just a
two-sentence thing i want to improve
communication through technology I
utilize these skills to help companies
build better communication systems boom
you've got your summary you can move
into your experience try and keep it
short try and relate it to the job
you're applying for and talk more about
why rather than what in your summary
thank you so much for your question
alright our other question was does
Udacity have a resume template with a
structure to have the most important
sections with a structure to have the
most important sections trying to make
sure I understand this question does
Udacity have a resume template with a
structure to have the most important
sections yeah alright so the most
important sections let's just kind of go
over real quick your experience is any
job that you've had in the past so if
really take a look at your LinkedIn what
does LinkedIn prioritize on their page
they base that off of the resume and
built upon it in building their website
so it's it's not a bad tool to use as a
reference because they did their
research to find out what's most
important for companies so number
front and center they have who you are
that's why we have a header on our
resume it's the same thing on LinkedIn a
header with your face in your name and
all that different stuff we won't put
our picture on the resume but that's
kind of where we're coming from
then your summary we have a summary on
LinkedIn we have a summary on your
resume again some people forgo the
summary on their resume I like to
include a very small one but that's
that's just my my perspective and so you
have your tiny summary and then you jump
right into your experience and that's
the way that LinkedIn prioritizes it as
well so you've got your experience
because that's what people want to know
the most now if you don't have
experience as as relevant as your
projects or your education you can move
those up but experience projects and
education are all three sections you
should absolutely have as well as your
skills so if you just have that in your
basic resume baseline you should be good
to go there's other things you can add
some people put hobbies interests things
like that
one thing that was really interesting is
early in my career I put that I was in a
band I was a lead singer and a band on
my resume and it came up in every single
interview that I went on we talked about
it we talked about shows and it was
interesting because number one is just a
weird thing not everyone has and number
two
it showed that I could give a
presentation it showed that I wasn't
scared of getting in front of a room and
that was part of the job that I was
applying for was being able to give good
presentations and get up in front of a
room so it was relevant
oddly enough to the role I was applying
for so if you have any interests or
hobbies that you think might make great
conversation starters in an interview I
wouldn't mind including those on your
resume I think at one point I had like
extracurriculars on my resume there's a
lot of different sections so if you just
do a little research take a look at some
resumes online you'll get a pretty good
sense of what it should look like and
then again just make it simple simpler
the better if it's getting complicated
if it's fallen to two pages if if you
can't fit it all just go back to basics
experience education skills projects
should be in a good spot
alright this is a great question my
jackass how can I identify the key words
that need to be in my resume to get a
recruiters attention this is a wonderful
question because at the end of the day
how do you find it you find it by
looking at job descriptions you want
your resume to look like the job
description that you're applying to so
what can you do you can go online again
we really need to be specific with the
jobs that we're applying for it's hard
to make a resume that matches five
different types of job roles so you want
to either have a single resume for every
job title you're going after or you want
to have one title that you're going
after with one resume attached to it so
what you can do is you can look up five
to ten versions of that job listing
write copy and paste all the content of
what the requirements of the job are put
it into a word cloud generator on Google
and it will show you which words come up
the most those are going to be the
keywords so you might find after doing
this a handful of times that there are
five or six different keywords that come
up in every single job application that
you see you'll want to make sure those
are on your resume if you have those in
your skill set and so you know a word
generator is one way to do it you could
also just read through and note the
things that you think are most important
but yeah I mean it shouldn't come from
nowhere it should come from what the
companies are looking for because those
are the keywords they're gonna be typing
in to find your resume right those are
the things that the resume screeners are
going to be trying to filter for so make
sure that you're actually basing it on
real application job job listings and
that'll that'll help you that'll help
you kind of put your best foot forward
and then you also asked what would get a
recruiters attention so when building
your resume what would get a recruiters
attention this is a tough one because
you know recruiters are trying to sift
through so many resumes they're really
looking for things that stand out so a
really strong educational background
with a big-name school a really strong
work background with a big name company
they look for keywords like that because
it shows that you've gone through the
rigorous job application process and
things like that in order to get to
where you are today so you're already
sort of pre vetted and so that's one of
the things that I've learned that
recruiters are looking for is people who
are sort of pre vetted so they don't
have to do the vetting on their own they
actually have a second source to confirm
that you've been that you can go through
these like complicated application
processes that we we all have to go
through and and make it to the end
because one of the things that
recruiters struggle with is like people
just disappearing they're talking with
the candidate they can't it just
disappears doesn't you know stops
replying to their emails and so we get
frustrated when recruiters stop
responding to us but we got to realize
that recruiters are getting ghosted all
the time so we have to have some
sympathy some empathy and we have to you
know help them make like if you really
want to work with recruiters you have to
help them make the sale for you they're
trying to sell you into a company so if
you can't convince them then they can't
convince the employer so you really want
to be setting yourself up with a strong
story a strong I would even say online
presence to backup being pitched for
these jobs but again I don't think that
that's always the best way to go I think
typically the best way to go about
getting a job is not through recruiters
but through networking and making your
own connections and finding personal
referrals inside a company that can get
you through the door it's much harder
and there's a lot of different ways to
get a job but 80% of jobs are found
through someone you know so I would
highly recommend going that route rather
than trying to you know finagle
everything to match what a recruiter
wants because what a recruiter wants
might be different than what other
people are looking for
[Music]
all right we've got
handful of questions that are all fairly
similar so I'm going to try and merge
them into one question here and dig in
alright so we've already
on the summary section the summary
section for someone who's fresh in their
job so Sanjeev any advice for writing an
attractive summary section for a fresher
yes talk about the future what do you
hope to achieve what impact are you
trying to have why do you want to do
this job it's much more important to say
why you want to do the job in your
summary than to just say what you can do
because what you can do is already
spelled out in the rest of the resume so
again focus on the why when you're
thinking about your summary if you're
wondering how to focus on your why take
a look at the start with why TED talk by
simon Sinek you just google it it'll
come up very interesting talk talks
about that it says people by why you do
what you do not what you do because
there's a lot of people that can you
know be programmers but how do you
actually or but what makes you different
than the other person alright a couple
of these questions kind of come down to
saying how do I stand out with my resume
the way you stand out with a resume is
by having it be easy to read and simple
and clear if it's easy to read simple
and clear I can actually scan it and
find the information I'm looking for
now beyond that your resume is not going
to be the thing that gets you the job
having some sort of amazing resume is
not um no one is picking up a resume and
going this is the greatest resume I've
ever seen I can't wait to hire this
person the way that they're doing it is
it's getting screened through these
online screeners these ATS systems it's
getting you know two-second scans from
interns it's getting all sorts of
different things that are making it
difficult for you to get through so
number one make sure there's no errors
in your resume if there's errors in your
resume you're out right away you're out
of the equation if it's so much
information like pack
down this page and I can't read any of
it if the formatting is all off if
everything is looking messy if there's
not consistent fonts and things are hard
to read I'm just my brains gonna go
scatter and I'm not gonna be able to
read through your resume and it's gonna
get put to the bottom of the pile you
just need it to be simple clear concise
and relevant and then people will scan
through it go oh yeah this person looks
like they've got some good background
all right moving on now I'm going to
look at their LinkedIn now I'm going to
google them now I'm gonna go find out
more information your resume is just one
of many parts of your application so
don't spend all your time on your resume
just make it clear concise and bring in
relevant information from past jobs that
would be beneficial here so working with
clients maybe helps you you know be able
to execute on on different sorts of you
know builds and things like that so you
can take in you know a request and
actually go do something with it so
there's a lot of different things from a
lot of different jobs that are relevant
make sure you include those skills as
well and if you're new you just have to
do the best with what you got what is
relevant what can you what can you
include that does make sense
and then if really at the end of the day
if you don't feel like you have enough
stuff filling out your resume you might
have to go build some things in order to
prop it up you might need to go create
some new stuff in order to fill in your
gaps and so I'd highly recommend doing
that as well at the end of the day you
know you can go volunteer for a meetup
groups you and then put that on your
resume there's all sorts of different
things you can do to make your
application stronger
[Music]
all right Raphael I've been unemployed
for two years due to a crisis here in
Brazil how can I present this fact in a
resume without it looking bad hmm I
guess my first question is where are you
applying for work are you applying for
work in Brazil where they understand
that and they understand the effects of
the past two years in that crisis are
you applying in the US I think that
would make a big difference the other
thing is I'm not quite sure how you can
address it in a resume now this might be
something you can address in a cover
letter might be something you can
address on your LinkedIn might be
something you can address even in the
interview especially in the interview
but I'm not entirely sure you can
address it on your resume I think the
best thing I could think of is like
putting in a little footnote or
something that references it but it just
might create more questions and answers
I'm not quite sure that that's the way
you want to go so this could be one of
those things where you need to be
networking your way into a job so you
have a personal reference and you need
to be able to explain what's been
happening over those two years while
you're in the interview and speak about
it confidently you know I mean maybe
you've been really trying and this is
just the situation I don't know all the
ins and outs of what's happening there
but it might not be something that can
be addressed in a resume it might be
something that you have to speak to
while networking and speak to while
interviewing I so you can give context
you there's just not enough context in a
resume to really get into the details
there all right our next
question is from Cali I have a four year
unemployment gap how can I cover that
gap in what should be what should be in
my summary this is a great question it's
hard for me to say what you need to say
to cover that gap because I don't know
what you did during that time were you
just taking a sabbatical for four years
were you you know raising a child were
you volunteering somewhere how did you
spend that time were you traveling maybe
you had a personal blog I'm not quite
sure but there's a lot of different
things that we can reference in order to
talk about unemployment gaps and if
you're currently in an unemployment gap
I would highly highly recommend you
either start volunteering somewhere you
join a professional organization you
build a meetup group or do something of
that sort in order to start shrinking
that gap that is currently growing or at
least stop the growth right so you want
to be doing something other than the job
search during the time that you're job
searching because number one it just
keeps you sane but number two it helps
you fill in those gaps that are slowly
widening right so I would highly
recommend that and then you know if you
Kelly if you have a little more
information on what you did during those
four years I think that would be helpful
again I don't necessarily think that we
address it in the resume it could be
something that we address in the cover
letter while networking during the
interview if it comes up some companies
care others don't so when you're putting
together your resume you know because it
is for years I have seen examples where
people say like you know there's ways I
don't know exactly how to say it so I'm
hesitating on just like blurting out
ways that you should write it but if you
take if you do some googling around like
how to explain you know being a
stay-at-home mom or something like that
during your application process there
are lots and lots of organizations that
are helping mothers get back into work
there's also a lot of organizations that
are helping people who are on sick leave
get back into work there's all sorts of
different reasons why people need to
take a break and you just need to own
your reason what was my reason recently
we were talking to someone who was had a
lot of medical issues and so they had to
take a few years to get their medical
issues in order but they can talk about
you know while I was going through these
medical issues I was dealing with
doctors scheduling budgeting all these
different things that are relevant to
the job might seem strange but you can
talk about it
again how do you put that in your resume
might be a more of an individual
discussion to see if it's gonna fit with
everything else that's on there it's not
gonna overshadow anything it's gonna
actually like make sense but in general
we typically talk about that stuff more
while networking and while interviewing
then on the resume itself I hope that
helps
how should art sorry
our next question is from sanda how
should I best represent my portfolio and
personal projects when I'm doing a
career change hmm personally I like to
showcase my personal project personally
my personal I enjoy showcasing my
personal projects as like the most
recent thing that I'm working on that's
relevant to the role typically if you're
working on some personal projects
they're relevant to what you're hoping
to do next in your career so if that's
the case for you what I would say is
give them a name give them some sort of
like professional sounding name and talk
about them as though they are work that
you're doing because they are work that
you're doing so for instance when I was
making career change
early on I wanted to go from the
marketing side of my corporate marketing
side to the agency world the advertising
side of things and you might think those
are pretty similar and they are but they
the two sides don't typically enjoy like
moving people from one to the other
there's a little bit of resistance there
so what I did was I built my own little
projects that would showcase the skills
I needed for the next role that I was
going
have I put on networking groups I I
built like journals I helped do some
like marketing and advertising stuff I
built some logos it was a sort of A
mish-mosh of a lot of different projects
that were going on during that time I
did some like brand coaching and things
of that sort and I just put it all under
one umbrella I put it all under the
umbrella of a thing that was called idea
lemon and I just said this is my side
project that I'm working on we host
events we do all these different things
and we partner with the American
Marketing Association and what ended up
happening without fail in almost every
interview I went on is that they were
more curious about the things that I was
building on my own and they were about
the work that I had done prior to that
so it ended up being a great
conversation piece it shows that you're
self-starter it shows that you're
someone who likes to build likes to
create isn't going to just sit around
doing nothing when they don't have
someone telling them what to do and so
these are things that if you are working
on personal projects really owned them
as though they are real work because
they are they're just as much work as
anything else I put on an event for a
company once that was just as hard as
putting on an event an event that I put
on just for fun
on my own and so these things are
relevant and they should be prioritized
as such and so if you can try and like
merge them together and what's funny is
that little side project ended up being
a company at a certain point it was
doing well enough that we ended up you
know launching a little company but it
started as a side project so may give
your side projects the weight that they
deserve and talk about them with
confidence as with anything else on your
resume don't skirt them under the rug
it's actually something pretty
interesting and something people are
pretty interested in
[Music]
all right our next
from jose if you're looking to change
careers from development to data science
is it more important to show what
projects you have worked on or sorry if
you're looking for change if you're
looking to change careers from
development to data science is it more
important to show what projects you have
worked on or do recruiters look for a
specific degree hmm so this is a really
interesting question recruiters are
looking for specific degrees at times
however if you don't have that degree
you should definitely be focused on the
projects you've been building basically
when it comes to the end of the day
whatever you've done that is most
relevant put that at the top so if it is
your degree put that at the top if it's
your personal projects but that at the
top of if it's your work experience put
that at the top I know you're going
through a career change right now so
it's going to be a little bit difficult
to you know stack that the top of your
resume but you you have more control
over the projects that you are currently
owning and building and they are likely
more related to the work you're trying
to do so I would typically put that
front and center unless you have like a
really strong degree from a really
reputable college or something like that
in which case maybe put that front and
center but again who are you trying to
impress are you trying to impress
recruiters hiring managers HR there's
there's all sorts of people reading
these resumes and so you really need to
know your audience at the end of the day
and so if your audience is recruiters
only I think you're actually limiting
your search a little bit I think you
need to start networking and finding
personal referrals in but each person
that you talk to might have a little bit
different of a focus so you can make
different versions of your resume for
different types of people maybe when
you're talking to recruiters you put
your education first and maybe when
you're applying to online job
you put your personal projects first and
I'll let you decide which one to do
there
from Devon what would be the resume
structure if you have 15 years of IT
experience but are making a career
change to data science Devon this is a
great question I don't necessarily have
enough information here I would need to
see your your resume so as a matter of
fact if you want to connect on LinkedIn
send it over I'll try and take a look
and give you a deeper answer here but if
you have anything that's related to data
science put it first that's that's just
how you're gonna need to make your
resume as we've been saying all
throughout put your data science stuff
first and then put your 15 years
experience in IT because your IT
experience is still going to be relevant
now again if you're making a resume
one-page I'll be able to go data science
project 15 years of IT experience rate
if it's two pages and I don't read to
the second page I might not see the rest
of your experience so try and keep it to
a page prioritize the things that are
most related to the role and then I'll
be reading onto the rest of your resume
all right our next question here is from
Sardar how do I approach my resume if I
have switched companies multiple times
after only a few months do I include it
or do I not it's a great question so it
really depends on those roles and why
you change jobs so frequently so I have
a number of different jobs that I've had
over the years some of them have been
you know up to three years some are one
to two years some are short six-month
contracts it's been all over the map
right and so when I think about what to
include I start by thinking about what's
most relevant then I back it up by
saying what do I actually want to talk
about when the interview Meek's when I
sit down for the interview they're gonna
pull up my resume they're gonna ask me
questions about what's on it so
sometimes I'll take things out that were
shorter projects or unrelated like I
take consulting work for a little bit
sometimes I'll take that out because
project management consulting just
wasn't as relevant as some of the other
things that I wanted to include in the
resume so what you want to think about
when you're doing these things like if
you were fired after only a couple
months and we bring that up in an
interview are you gonna want to talk
about it if there's like seven seven
switches within a few months like were
you a contractor were you a freelancer
were they internships what were those
things as long as you can talk about it
in a confident way I'd include it
however you also don't want to come
across as someone who's going to be
leaving in three months so I would try
and not have that be the only thing
that's on your resume try and include
some things that you've actually stuck
with for more than a few months in order
to balance out that those two sides of
your work experience sometimes you do
short projects sometimes you do long
projects so try and keep it balanced and
again if it's something that you don't
want to talk about don't include it
alright here's a great question
what about resume design tech trick is
it better to make a cool design for a
resume and how do I keep it focused on
the important stuff alright this is
something going all the way back to my
early years I was a design minor so I
thought myself a great designer for a
little bit and while I can do some basic
design and it's alright I was in a job
that wasn't very creative create
creatively focused so I put all my
creativity into this into this resume
and my resume back in the day like my
resume right now is one page I use a
Google template and I try to keep it
pretty straightforward it's got some
like shading some different colors and
stuff but it was all part of the
template and I liked it so I kept it but
back in the day I had this two-page
resume and I would print it out front
and back which of course no one would
read it was like black and yellow and
had all sorts of like reverse colors and
it was bad yeah I go back and I cringe
looking at that resume and it's one of
those things where I thought I was being
cool and I thought I was making myself
stand out and what's interesting about
trying to be cool is that typically it
comes off as trying too hard
so unless you're gonna do something like
the guy who created a Mario video game
for his resume where you are literally
playing the video game as you go through
his resume I would just keep it simple
keep it there's this concept in in
marketing called kiss keep it simple
Sally and really at the end of the day
what you're trying to do is communicate
the value you can bring to the company
and how you can solve their problems
you're not trying to show off so I would
discourage showing off and encourage
simplicity and clear communication so
how do you keep it focused on the
important stuff look at the job you're
applying for look at what they need and
talk about how you can help
them solve those needs if you do that
well during the job search process
you're going to do well in the job
search process thank you for that
question though I think that's something
that's on a lot of people's minds just
because we are creative we'd like to be
creative people like it's not a bad
thing it's just you have to know your
audience you have to know the right time
and place to be creative be more
creative on your personal website you
get full control over your personal
website go wild you know make it as
interesting as you want or your personal
blog or whatever the thing might be one
of the biggest benefits of LinkedIn is
that is so simplified it's so easy to
read it's so easy to scroll through that
and and find the right terms and the
right experience that you know people
use it all the time companies love to
use it in order to find candidates so I
think simplicity wins on this one all
right Paul
how should I format my resume
functionally or chronologically this is
actually one that's up for debate I've
always done chronological but I have
changed the sections in order to you
know prioritize things so you know early
on in my career education was first
experience a second
now experiences first education is last
so I typically like to prioritize based
on section however I've seen people do
it based on functionality so if you just
have a lot of projects that you've built
you know you could prioritize it based
off project and the timeline doesn't
really matter when it comes to projects
you might have done a dozen projects or
in a short timeline in a long timeline
but they're all projects so they all go
to the top of your resume so in your
case Paul what do you think is most
important put that at the top I I would
start there and then and then show it to
a few people to see if it's confusing if
it's out of order
all right maybe even send it to me if
and it's extremely confusing and I'm not
quite sure and don't really understand
your progress here we might want to
think a little bit but in general put
your most relevant stuff at the top try
and keep it as chronological
as you can again it's one page so it
doesn't need to all be like you don't
need to be going like experience
education experience project experience
you know and so on you don't you don't
want to mix the sections that'll get
confusing you you just want it to be
clear and easy to understand I want to
know how you got here and why we're
talking that's really what I want to
know at the end of the day so try and
try and do that and keep it simple keep
it as chronological as you can but if
there are certain things that you just
have to get to the top of that resume we
there could be an argument for it so I I
would personally keep it chronological
unless otherwise needed but if there's
something that you're like if they don't
see this I'm not they're not gonna want
to consider me which seems a bit out
there but you know there is an argument
to be made so personally chronological
you know where I stand but I could I
could see the argument for functionally
all right our next question is from noob
Pro training are there are the ready to
fill resume templates online a good way
to go or is it better to make it from
scratch
now the three thing this is a great
question the three things that I've seen
is making it totally from scratch which
all my first resumes were made totally
from scratch I would put them in Adobe
Illustrator I would try and get as much
information as I could I'd give the
margins as small as I could and I
sometimes over designed it sometimes
designed it just right but it was a very
personal very focused very customized
resume for myself I've also seen the
things where you type in a bunch of
fields like you're filling out a form
and it imports it into a resume for you
but then you have very limited ability
to edit or change anything so you might
have like a hanging word that takes up a
whole line it might not all fit on a
page it might look a little wonky just
because you know your what your
in putting won't fit perfectly into that
rigid template it's so rigid right you
can't change a single thing you can just
fill in the fields I personally don't
like those because I lose control like
I'm someone who used to build them all
from scratch in Adobe Illustrator and
now I have zero control over the format
and and the feel and how much content I
can include and the margins and
everything like that so I settled for
something in the middle I'd like to get
Google templates Google Drive Google Doc
templates that are highly customized but
then I can actually go in and edit on my
own so I can change the margin I can
delete the photo that they had in there
I can shorten this change the font size
of that add in some more fields widen
different things so that's my compromise
my compromise is it's not my own design
because I'm not a designer and we're not
trying to prove myself as a designer but
it is well-designed and it's something
that I can customize to my liking so we
rather than just having a very bland you
know word doc I have a bit more of a
customized word doc from these templates
online which I can then customize a
little bit more so that's my middle
ground and what I would highly recommend
other people to do so they can fit all
their information in but if you really
are not comfortable with Google Docs
well first I'd recommend that you become
comfortable with Google Docs but if you
really aren't and you just want to fill
in those forms and it looks good give it
a shot
if it's not getting results try
something else but that's how I would go
about it I would say you know the main
thing is to be clear and concise and
however you can do that is the best way
to go all right we're coming to the last
four minutes here so I'm going to see
which ones I can jump it on right away
sardar how should i write a four to five
lines summary in my resume again your
summary should be one to two sentences
and you should say like why this
industry is interesting and how your
experience is going to help the company
so for me it's like my goal is to help
people reduce their anxiety and find
jobs that they reduce their anxiety
during the job search and find jobs that
they love I do this with or I merge a
background in marketing career
development coaching etc in order to
help companies improve their student
outcomes boom very short of course it's
better worded I'm doing this off top my
head but it's it's right there it's
really quick really short really to the
point the more you put in that the more
complicated it all gets so try and keep
it short and sweet and talk about the
why more than the what is the what is
the rest of the resume hmm this is a
really big question I'm gonna see if we
can end on this let me see alright our
next question is from my tray I feel I'm
not realizing my potential how do I get
a job that uses all my building
abilities sorry let me read it again I
feel like I'm not realizing my potential
how do I get a job that uses all of my
abilities the first thing I'll say in
regards to this is that we can't put
that much we really shouldn't put that
much into them what we shouldn't put
that much of an expectation on our job
your potential is filled in many ways
throughout your life not just through
your career your potential is filled
through the work that you do your job
which will you know if you're thinking
about a pie that's part of the pie
some people work is a bigger piece of
their pie than others but then you also
have family then you also have friends
then you also have hobbies then you also
volunteer work then you also have
charity right there are lots of ways to
fill your potential don't
put all of your eggs in one basket if we
do that it does a number of things that
are not so great for our psyche it puts
a lot of stress behind the job search
because it makes us want to find
something that's perfect and there is no
perfect job there are jobs that are
great there are jobs that are not so
great and there's jobs in between but
typically you will not be 100% fulfilled
by the work you do every day now things
that help you become more fulfilled in
your work are working in an industry
that matters to you maybe you are really
interested in you know the future of
self-driving cars artificial
intelligence something along those lines
something that keeps your interest
beyond the day-to-day drudgery but then
you're also going to have day-to-day
drudgery everyone has emails everyone
has meetings everyone has the grunt work
that they need to get done and that
needs to be part of what you are
expecting in your job so you want to go
in with realistic expectations and I
think what ends up happening is people
want to find this dream role this dream
company that will solve all all their
wants and needs and then they get there
six months in they've normalized all the
excitement has come down and then
they're upset and they're unhappy well
that's just always going to be the cycle
so when it comes to realizing your
potential take a step back and define
what potential you mean what exactly are
you trying to accomplish what exactly
what skills are you to the forefront so
you know I worked in marketing I I was
selling credit cards I didn't feel like
I was reaching my full potential I was
doing a lot of Excel sheets I wasn't
really interacting with anyone I wasn't
getting any like feedback from things
that I was doing so I said I'm gonna
help people build their personal brands
I don't know maybe that'll be cool I
like logos I like things like that so I
did that that led to coaching coaching
led to this right now I'm getting closer
to reaching my full potential but still
a ways off not everything is the best it
could be and so when you're thinking
about all these things think about it as
an
Ellucian over time you are always
growing you're always striving to reach
your potential but we probably will
never get to our full potential because
our potential keeps widening every time
we learn something new so take some of
the stress off yourself find a job that
allows you to do a good job every day
that allows you to do good work and then
keep growing from there thank you all
for watching I really appreciate you
joining us for today's ask a career
coach super excited for next week when
we will be doing this again the link is
in the description if you'd like to sign
up for next week's session share it with
your friends thank you Karen for sending
over all the questions thank you all for
joining us for the first time or if
you're a repeat viewer keep coming back
to keep bringing your questions that we
will keep answering them
appreciate your time and have a great
rest of the day and good luck in your
job search